hey everyone I'm Liana Giller from
Entertainment Tonight and Richard Rankin
from Outlander who plays Roger McKenzie
is joining me right now how's it going
good thank you
I'm doing well thank you you know we're
having some drinks in a pub yes well
this is my ad my local thang here all
the time so much happens for Roger in
season four yeah how are you even
beginning to tease it to the fans right
now he changes it was an evolution to
that character which is explored and
details through season four they're all
local star aid you know it's really
funny is that's exactly how so if we
describe Brees journey just copy copies
me I just said that because I know
that's what Sophie had said and I just
wanted to know how and tune her own
touch I am with hot character I'm very
excited to see the Scottish Festival
seen the festival stuff scary it was a
lot of good fun we had were to be stalls
and shops and Gap shops and popcorn
stands and a big flaming stag as you do
we bombed a stag
I'm that's the thing about season 4 as
well as there's there's just so many
wheels - and they're all very much
contrasting with each other so there's
just something enough whatever you want
it's brilliant I love that you're
conveniently leaving out one crucial
detail from that day I know what you're
thinking hmm yeah I work help well
that's - actually I was thinking of the
fact that you sing for Brianna oh yeah
yeah no you know what I told everyone
absolutely not
so they had Gavin made an arrangement of
a song that for the guitar turns out it
was ahead of time so that's a federal
track it's like 165 beats per minute and
so I basically spent every minute of
every day
wailing to play that track and drive the
crew nuts that was fun you still can't
believe what a great musician you are
what other talents are you've been
keeping from me
no nevel till roger and bri get a lot
closer together in this upcoming season
and you guys do film a more intimate
scene are you telling me what we've seen
well Briana feeds Roger chips not quite
it was really nice because I think we
have a lot of trust in each other
yeah those actors and then a lot of
confidence and walking with each other
so there was never any um there was
never any issues there I feel that we
could really you know connect so what
glands I don't have a clan I mean I
guess I'm a Fraser but my boyfriend's on
McKenzie
[Music]